hey guys what's up we got to talk all
about the flash so just careful for
spoilers from the episode if you haven't
seen it yet
oh my god future flash costume I know
it's not the blue flash but they're
still leaving the door open for some
interesting twists with saboteur so if
you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get everything I do Marvel
and DC videos every week there's a flash
ring giveaway going on right now that
I'll explain at the end of the video I
know everybody's wondering about the
show going on break what's happening is
they're coming back at the end of April
if you remember last year they went on
break I think it was during March it was
just earlier in the year it was the same
break so it is a bummer but I'll be
doing bonus videos so no worries but top
10 WTF and comic book Easter Egg so
start with number 10 welcome to
abracadabra so he debuted back in 1962
he's created by carmine infantino who
created most of the flash rogues gallery
at least all the classic rogues that you
guys are familiar with but the big twist
is gypsy sort of explains later in the
episode is that you someone from the
future with like crazy technologies it
just makes it look like he can perform
magic so in the future what happens is
is they have a time machine but nobody
is impressed by magic it's all a world
of science is so boring so he's like I
want to perform so he steals the time
machine comes back into the past so that
he has a crowd to appreciate him any
search using his technology to commit
crimes which is where the flash comes in
and that's how they become enemies but
the thing is is he is the current record
holder from furthest person in the
future to travel back so you Bart dawn
is from the 25th century
he's from the 64th century so however
advanced you think the reverse flashes
technology is he has stuff that's way
cooler but most of its stuck in the
future he doesn't have that much stuff
with them the way they explain it is it
is just nanotechnology built into his
body and that's how it looks like he's
performing all those crazy magic tricks
but number 9 welcome back to Stagg
industries we haven't been there since
season one I think I can't remember any
time the last couple seasons
besides that second episode where they
name dropped them and that was when the
reverse-flash killed Simon Stagg because
he was going to try and take Barry on
for himself the introductions an easter
egg for the Houdini water tank effect
you know most of the times you see that
pop up in movies and TV shows somebody
dies trying to attempt it just because
it's so deadly
so the fact these two people died
unusual but Barry's doing actual CSI
work we learned a little bit about where
everyone's relationships are like Cisco
super hyped up about [ __ ] Julianne and
Caitlin are kind of cooled off but then
Barry finally runs into abracadabra
himself surprise surprise there at cord
industries we haven't seen them since
they've been on arrow they use them on
arrow as sort of like the default go to
things that damian darhk-- would steal
weapons from Ted Kord is like this big
character he was originally supposed to
be who Brandon Rao's character was but
DC was like nope you can't use them so
Ted Kord is now just like this faceless
person in the DC Universe in number 8
the carrot gets dangled 15 minutes into
the episode did not take long I know
everything about you I'm from the future
I know all about savat are so it lays
that seed in Barry's head is he going to
take the bait and let him go if he can
get information on sabotage what kind of
a hero is he going to be he's still
trying to live down flashpoint they even
talked about it during the musical
episode like he's sang a song where he's
like yeah I'm not supposed to go back in
time anymore but the whole thing about
this episode is they were hyping it up
is it they were going to reveal the
identity of Savitt r he knows he's going
to tell somebody someone's going to find
out before another member of the group
so that's why I was so happy when Joe
was the one to go in because it's always
fun to watch him go hardcore because
he's like mr. nice dad so he goes crazy
when he goes off the chain like in
season 2 when he was punching Harrison
wells
but number 7 we learned why he's come to
STAR Labs he's looking for something
that the reverse-flash has to build a
time machine what else do you wonder is
in there because team flash didn't seem
like they knew about that otherwise they
probably would have picked that clean
Julianne drops a money Python reference
when Caitlin's treating him they slowly
start coming back together and even
though Barry almost gets to save I
talked it up as a win for Cisco's panic
button system I thought that was a
throwaway joke at the beginning of the
season but it's come in handy a couple
times this year and really I think the
whole point behind that is just to
address the logic issue of people having
cell phones that's usually a big problem
for stories because if you were like
walking alone in a horror film and
someone was tailing you wouldn't you
just call 911 in that way number six we
learned gypsy is pissed at the idea of
not taking him right back to earth 19 to
face the death sentence she really
to chop his head off it's crazy and it
take most of the episode to find out why
but she just has a really personal stake
in it just like everybody else and they
wanted to do that just so that you
wouldn't demonize gypsy or you wouldn't
demonize Joe because you care about iris
West you don't want her to die maybe you
feel like gypsy was justified in wanting
revenge and justice for all the people
that he killed including her former
boyfriend and partner someone that she
was really close to but number five
abracadabra starts talking about
sabotage and it confirms some of the
things that Jay Garrick said the biggest
thing being that he was the first person
that was granted speed so when Jay
Garrick was explaining it they had this
actor here who just looked completely
jacked you know you're not meant to see
his face just then he looked like he was
really buff when the Philosopher's Stone
was giving him his speed so I know a lot
of people want to believe the Barry as
savat our theory that the future flash
is Savitt our he becomes the future
flash because the costume does look kind
of blue like the blue flash costume of
the future in the other future flash
costume that we saw at the end of the
episode looks kind of like the new 52
version of the red costume so it's like
oh you know maybe they're doing a
version of that storyline so there are a
lot of details and seeming coincidences
that seem to point towards Barry's
avatar things but it's not confirmation
or anything like that this person that
saboteur is seems like a completely
different person unless they're lying to
us so you guys can let me know in the
Sabbat our flashback where jay garrick's
talking about him do you think that this
person is actually Salvatore or do you
think it's just his idea of Salvatore
and he's never seen him as a human so
the show was just presenting us with
false information because false
narration is a big thing on TV now mr.
robot does that all the time where you
see from Elliott's perspective but
because he's so messed up in the head he
doesn't know what reality is so what
we're seeing is not reality
so whatever your saboteur theories are
they're still wide open and then there's
the idea that HR was just mysteriously
gone for no reason for two days he said
he was with a woman but he's a really
fast talker so that could be
misdirection so HR whereabouts unknown
but number four Joe goes off the chain
you tell me I'll let you go I will kill
you if you try to move and he does
actually try to kill them later in the
episode that's how hardcore Joe is oh
I've changed the terms of our agreement
seems like you
as well but even though the show kind of
wants you to feel like Joe isn't
thinking clearly because he's so worried
about iris I didn't really feel that
remorseful about what he did I mean I
would have done the same thing in his
position too so it's not like you feel
bad about Joe you feel more bad about
what gypsy is doing even though she's
probably more justified you care more
about the team flash characters so you
guys can let me know which side did you
come down on team flash Civil War team
gypsy or team Joe West but he gets away
builds a time machine it looks a little
bit like the comic book version of the
time machine I mean it was done back in
so the drawings were way more primitive
but it's just the idea that he had a
time machine that got into the past he's
rebuilding one to get him back to the
future so it was an Easter Egg for that
but number three team flash rolls out in
math to chase him down you have Wally
Barry Cisco and gypsy you shall not pass
nice Lord of the Rings reference Barry
looks like he's gone faster than he's
ever gone and phases them out so it was
a really badass save on his part it's
just a way to show you that he still has
the a game of anyone on Team flash any
of the speedsters no matter what they've
done while he's done some cool stuff
Barry is still the fastest most skilled
version of the flash that they have when
Jay Garrick isn't around Jay Garrick has
more skills but he's not quite as fast
as Barry but Barry's big takeaway from
the whole thing is that hey the villains
they always know more about us so I'm
going to go to the future so we'll talk
about that in my next video because
there is a new character that they cast
for the future part of the storyline
so I'll explain that whenever I post so
number two though Caitlyn gets operated
on hard core while she's awake helping
Julianne operate on her but surprise
surprise blame the lime jello blame
whatever you want she goes into cardiac
arrest and whatever it is that happens
inside of her it triggers her to go
full-blown
killer frost so this is what she's going
to look like presumably for the rest of
the season maybe even into season four
depending on which direction her
character takes because she comes out of
there seeming pretty evil but I love the
makeup job and it actually doesn't look
that invasive so if they were to do a
full season of her as killer frost it
doesn't seem like it would be that much
harder from a production perspective
they even mentioned the thinker as one
of the future big flash villains so he
might come into play in season four
maybe we'll get some Easter eggs for him
later in the season but he's just
another big flash villain from
Golden Age he goes all the way back but
there been a couple different versions
of the character so if it seems that
they're going to do them all totally do
a video about it but number one big
thing is we saw Barry in the future
seeing the future version of himself in
the new costume so everybody was
wondering when are we going to get a new
costume Grant Gustin even tweeted this
way earlier this year it's about time
Barry got a new costume so this is where
that comes in but I think what's going
on here is that they're taking more
inspiration from the Lightning curves
that go over his body in the comic book
so it's a little more comic book
accurate well let me know what do you
think about the future flash costume
what do you think about the abracadabra
twist they were hyping up that they were
going to reveal who's avatar was so I
was a little disappointed that they
pulled the rug out from under us but
Barry is just going to try to find out
one more way so all of the cast keeps
saying that we're going to be completely
surprised with who it is so I know there
are a couple really big theories there's
the very theory there's the HR theory
there's the theory that it's somebody
that we've never seen before someone
that's not on Team flash but it will be
a familiar face so what will happen next
is I'll post that flash trailer video
tomorrow there'll be some new spider-man
homecoming and you guys can let me know
in the comments what bonus videos do you
want me to do during the break while we
wait for flash to come back so
congratulations to this week's giveaway
winner toaster you win one of the flash
rings please private message me on the
back end of my channel so I can get your
contact details there was a new round
that started in this video on ounce the
winner when I post that trailer video
tomorrow while you wait for that click
here to learn about the reverse-flash
easter egg and the Justice League
trailer and you click here for the
spider-man trailer thank you so much for
watching let's high five I'll see you
guys in the next video
you